musique
ce matin là nous avons pris un grand
bateau gris
là le frère [ __ ] ruisselant de damouzy
mme blanche traverser l'atlantique avec
famille et tous ses cheveux blancs la
houle sur la dune est le capitaine nos
gardes à moitié marin sirène il envoie
des baisers au loin
qu'elle est belle la gonzesse qui
déambulent de l'autre côté du pont
qu'elle est belle je suis sûr qu'elle a
du pognon c'est mam et qui me dit touche
pas mon petit gars touche pas sans ça tu
vas aller au ballon et le ballon dans
l'eau
ce matin le vent
ma mamie c'est une dure 11 par avec les
économies de son patron il a dit c'est
pas normal que tu fasses ta vie dans ce
pays city
hammami c'est une dure un pétard dans
son cabas est dit comme ça que c'est si
jamais on nous empêcher d'aller là bas
lt comme sac raul était jamais arrivé à
new york il avait flingué sur le quai il
ya vingt ans déjà
walls été moment
il m'emmenait au bord de la mer et
regarder l'horizon il disait un jour on
va se casser qui fera du cheval tout nu
torah des copains bien je te regarde
règlement rocking chair d'hiver a ma
gueule ça mais faut du pognon police
open à sa grand mère
je fais des bisous
passez le temps nous n'avons jamais vu
new york 17 d'un et femelles quittant le
point le bateau a coulé mami a basculé
dans l'éternité
le seul survivant il fait pourtant c'est
tellement grand que j'ai pas le temps
d'avoir du chemin avec tous ces requins
qui veulent savoir comment je m'appelle
je leur dis mais je veux pas qu'ils
bouffent mamie c'est d'accord ni gros
griot touche près la vieille dame aux
cheveux d'argent elle peut dormir pena
rompu fera l'équipe démarre
n'est ce pas une
tout à coup j'entends crier joint un
drôle d'oiseau qui vient vers moi en
pagayant avec ses ailes multicolores
je m'appelle bokoko dit il tout
essoufflé je suis plus beau des coqs
je dormais quand on a coulé france
benoît hamon petit coche peu plus ravi
avec mais elle emmène moi dans le
village là où ma mère et pépé
aide-moi dans le village là où les
femmes ont des robes qui ressemble à des
millions de solifor ram tout droit mon
petit gars
ram tout droit mon petit gars
en mai nous là bas là bas l'abba robben
nous dans le village là où notre mère
est peut-être née au men nou dans le
village raoult papa est un sage
en mai nous dans le village là où les
femmes ont les robes qui ressemble à des
millions de soles et fou
ce matin là nous avons fait
un grand retour
l'un de freiner
ici
je retournais
m
sur le tard
coût
merci richard